مجهودات الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد
ترامب في بسط السيطره على الحزب الجمهوري
قد تذهب ادراج الرياح فترامب الذي سعى الى
تشكيل الحزب الجمهوري وفق تصوره اختار
اسماء بعينها لدعمها من بينها قبل ما
كارتي ورغم دعم ترامب الا ان مكارثي لا
يزال يواجه اقليه معارضه لم تلتفت لدعوات
الرئيس الامريكي السابق صحيفه نيوز ويك
وصفت الامراض بان ترامب فقد السيطره على
الوحش الذي صنعه وتطرحه هذه الواقعه
تساؤلات بشان هويه الحزب ومستقبله كما
انها تذكير جديد بتراجع نفود ترامب داخل
الحزب الجمهوري وهذا التخبط مشاهدينا في
مواقف النواب الجمهوريين قد يؤثر سلبا على
الحزب في التحديات الانتخابيه المقبله
بحسب مجله نيك بهذا الشرح داخل الحزب من
شانه ان ينفر بعض الناخبين في الانتخابات
المقبله كما ان اصطدام المحتمل يلوح في
الافق بين اثاره ومعارضه
كبيرا وقد يؤدي هذا الانقسام لفرغ على
مستوى مراكز القياده القادره على توحيد
المواقف والاراء